الليليه اندلعت بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع في مناطق قريبه من شارع
الستين والجنوب الغربي للعاصمه بعد هدوء
لم يدم طويلا
بعد الان من جديد من محيط مطر مروي في جبل
السودان وراس الجزيره اسامه سيدي احمد ومن
الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره هيثم او ترحب بكما
ابدا معك هيثم جديد المشهد بعد ان كنت
معنا في الساعه الماضيه وقعت قذيفه بالقرب
منك نتمنى لك السلامه طبعا
نعم هذه الاشتباكات ما تزال مستمره
ونطاقها يتسع يعني في كل مره نسمع بان هذه
الاشتباكات تحولت من منطقه لمنطقه وطبعا
هي يعني حرب كروه فروه هي يعني
تدور في اكثر من موقع واكثر من محور يبدو
انه لم يكن او لم يظل وسط الخرطوم هو
الساحه الوحيده الان لهذه المعارك هناك
كانت معارك في اتجاه الشارع النيل وايضا
شارع الستين وايضا منطقه الشرق النيل
وعديد من المناطق التي يعني تشهد اشتباكات
مسلحه بين القوات الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع سبق طبعا هذه الاشتباكات قصف
في الصباح ساعات الصباح قصفيه قويه
لقذائف يبدو انها اسلحه ثقيله او ربما
مدرعات كانت تستخدم في في الصباح وبعد ذلك
اعقب ذلك القصف
الاشتباك المباشر الذي حدث في اكثر من
موقع وماذا لا نزال حتى هذه اللحظه ان
نسمع يعني اصوات الاشتباكات واصوات
القسوه الانفجارات التي تحدث من الحين الى
الاخر وايضا نشاهد يعني اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد من العديد من المواقع التي تاثرت
بنتيجه لهذا القصف خاصه منطقه في بحري وفي
وسط الخرطوم هذه هي المناطق التي يعني
اشتد فيها القتال
العمل الميداني الذي يجري الان حتى الان
يعني هذا الحراك هو سيد الموقف
الاشتباك المسلح او حتى الان لا توجد اي
بوادر الى تهدئه ربما توقف هذا القتال
المستمر منذ ثلاثه ايام وحتى الان رغم
يعني توالي الدعوات وتوالي النداءات سواء
كانت من الداخل السوداني من يعني الشخصيات
او احزاب سياسيه التجمعات شعبيه او حتى
قطاعات وافراد من داخل السوداني وايضا
الدعوات الاقليميه والدوليه التي تنادي
بالوقف الفوري لهذا وقف لهذا الاشتباك
وهذه هذا التدهور المريع في الوضع الامني
في الخرطوم والذي يخشى ايضا تشهده بعض
المواقع او المدن الخارج مدينه الخرطوم
ومدن السودان الاخرى البعض يتخوف او
الجميع يتخوف من ان تتسع نطاق رقعه هذا
هذه احدى القذايف القويه التي نسمعها يعني
الان يعني
اشتباكات عنيفه تدور في في مواقع عده
ويبدو ان تاثيرات هذا
الاشتباك الدائري يعني ستكون عواقبه وخيمه
على مستقبل هذا البلد وعلى البنيه التحتيه
وعلى ايضا الضحايا الذين سقطوا وتزداد
يعني اعدادهم وفقا للجنه الاطباء المركزيه
التي ترفع اصواتها بالنداء والاستغاثه
يعني
نقص الكوادر في المستشفيات واقتضاض
المستشفيات بالمصابين وبانها اصبحت يعني
لا تتحمل طاقتها اكثر مما هو عليه الان
نتيجه لانقطاع او يعني معظم الناس محتجزين
حتى القوادر الطبيه محتجزه خارج في مناطق
سواء كان في منازلهم او في مناطق عملهم
ولا يستطيعون التواصل او الخروج والوصول
الى اماكن عملهم مما يصعب حتى سيارات
الاسعاف يعني تجد صعوبه في الحركه لانغاز
او اسعاف المصابين رغم ان هناك هدنه يعني
اتفق عليها الطرفان الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السرعي لفتره ثلاث ساعات لاعطاء
فرصه لخروج المدنيين والتحرك ولكن في ظل
هذا التصعيد وهذه الاجواء يبدو انه من
الصعب
الاستجابه وربما تنفيذ هذه الهدنه ما
نشاهده الان هو يعني واقع مغاير واقع
مختلف تماما الخرطوم تعيش على وقع الصفيح
ساخن من هذه المواجهات التي لا يعلم احد
متى ستنتهي